all right b
hey b uh where'd you girl where are you
from originally
um i grew up in marin but i was born in
san francisco
um moran like in fairfax
and tell me tell me about your childhood
um i kind of had a
really um solitary childhood i guess
um i raised myself i ran away when i was
12.
um i just kind of like
did what i could for money so i started
selling drugs
and uh at 12 yeah 12. um
i was like already an adult at 12. um
i met this guy and we moved to santa
rosa
and um i went back to school
when i was like 16 and just kind of
tried to like
go back to school like i never left and
um they ended up giving me like a ged
test and i graduated early so then i was
like yeah
i'm totally an adult now like you know
and so
uh i just started just uh
doing like cna like taking care of
elders
and selling dope at the same time
so i was making a lot of money i was
taking care of a bunch of people
and uh it just overwhelmed me a lot so i
ended up going to jail
a lot i spent most of my like
adult life in jail so far how do you
know
um i'm 29. so drugs drug you started
early for you it sounds like
no believe it or not it did not so
you're selling yeah i was saying dressed
uh up until like two years ago so like
13 years or something so the drug use
just started recently yeah it started
like four or five years ago
yeah i had this boyfriend that was like
beating me up like really bad um
he was like stalking me i couldn't do
anything i couldn't go to work
and um he ended up like smashing my face
through this tv
and i started using because i was like
in so much pain all the time
you know um a friend of mine convinced
me that it was like a good idea
to do oxycontin it would help with the
pain and so
it just like stuck so i went from
obvious cotton
to heroin to cocaine
um and now it's like cracking fentanyl
man so it's only been like four or five
years i'm just like
moving up you up so
how do you support your your drug habit
uh you know i was so tired of going to
jail all the time i did
um a prison sentence in
county which is like worse than prison
um
and so i moved away from marin
and came to the city i didn't want to
sell dope anymore so
um i tried like everything
that i could like um i was doing a lot
of like strong arms and then
uh i did a lot of pimping and then you
know
all that type of stuff and then i tried
to get sober i met my wife
and um i started working at chipotle
you know that was cool
after my wife she actually passed away
like two years ago
yeah and she was like everything i had
so i kind of just like
um i just started doing
i guess worse you know and um when
you're doing
worse you kind of start doing stuff you
told yourself you never do
you know i mean so um yeah now i'm like
an escort you know something i always
promised myself i'd never do
so yeah i'm just dealing with that
but it's good money today kind of makes
it worth it
yeah is it dangerous sometimes um no
it's more dangerous for them
if anything you know i mean and so
i've never actually like had any bad
situations like that you know
how long you've been doing it um like a
year and a half now
yeah and you're doing it no pimp you're
just doing it on your own oh no hell no
yeah
never that yeah you do it through the
internet online stuff yeah
online stuff yeah uh it's more like
um like people pay me for like my
company yeah
you know pretty good entertainment yeah
you know what can you make in like an
hour or something
an hour like 700 dollars really yeah
yeah it's pretty cool it's good stuff
you know
and i get to like you know only go as
far as i'd like to
you know yeah you get asked to do a lot
of crazy stuff oh yeah well yeah
um a lot of weird stuff you know um it's
kind of hard like sometimes though
because
i'm more interested in like women you
know so
um it's kind of like i guess it gave her
pay it's kind of what it's like for me
you know
does this lifestyle get you down
sometimes you get depressed or yeah a
lot
actually it's not hard to deal with yeah
um it was cool until like um my wife
passed away
i've just been like dealing with that
you know
um so i like relapsed when she passed
away
and uh i just like haven't stopped
so yeah and your customers the guys
that'll
that you'll date do you respect these
guys do you
just tolerate them or i just kind of try
to like
put on my acting face and like black out
kind of
you know when i was a kid i used to like
disassociate a lot
like when i was dealing with like abuse
and stuff like that so i just kind of
like
go away for saying you know what i mean
yeah it kind of helps you know
are you saving money um no
not at all no no i smoked like a
thousand dollars with the crowd today
yeah yeah it's a lot
you believe in karma yeah you know it's
so funny that you say that because
i do believe in karma you know just
telling somebody the other day
like that's like revelation and uh
i feel like i'm living somebody's like
second life sentence
does that make sense you know like you
can't really do a second
life sentence unless you're in a new
life right
yeah because i feel like i'm paying for
somebody's karma for sure
is there anything that you do whether
it's turning tricks or doing drugs or
anything like that that you feel
you're doing anything that would affect
your karma
oh hell yeah you know um like when i
first started
uh using crack i was like so embarrassed
you know
it's like dude crack was like in the 70s
or the 80s or whatever like people still
do that [ __ ] you know i mean
just doesn't sound right just like crack
you know
so it's still a very popular drug yeah
hell yeah it is
and so um i would go in the bathroom a
lot and like
lie about stuff and tell people i was
just like using the bathroom for hours
like
you know and um when people start
finding out
i kind of didn't want to like go through
it by myself so i'd like get people to
start smoking with me and
you know i still like think about it a
lot you know
just like i sure like probably
like you know i don't know i try to be
the best person i can be
um you know like these
streets and like situations out here can
like really wear people down
and like certainly around people yeah
everyone's
been doing something shady exactly so
it's like you got to kind of try
like yeah you know what i mean and like
i don't know i feel like out here like
nobody is really
like mindful of other people so i'm like
trying to be mindful even though nobody
else is
it's just really hard you have anyone in
your life that you truly
trust and who really looks out for you
your best interest
[Music]
no you have friends
acquaintances yeah i guess yeah
you know yeah i go with that did the
shame
play a part in your life yeah definitely
it's hard to like um
like deal with a situation like
doing something on your list of [ __ ]
you'll never do like
you know and then you wake up in the
morning you're like [ __ ] i did that [ __ ]
that sucks you know and then you have to
like live the rest of your life like
thinking about it
what are your biggest regrets um
i definitely shouldn't have ran away
you know um i feel like my life probably
would have been like way different
yeah i think that's about it i don't
know working
really sucks
how do you feel like this lifestyle has
changed you you've been kind of working
the streets since you were a young girl
yeah i mean like i don't know i'm
definitely like
streets heavy and stuff sometimes people
tell me i'm
uh charismatic yeah i mean so i guess
it's
kind of made me a little well-rounded
somehow you feel like you're addicted
not just to the drug but the lifestyle
as well um
yeah definitely because you know when i
got sober i still was like
selling dope and um you know doing stuff
working at chipotle was probably just
too boring yeah it was it was like so
boring i was like falling asleep at the
register and stuff like that you know i
mean
so i ended up getting laid off and you
know
it's just i wasn't able to like maintain
my like career choice you know
um because all my felonies and stuff
like that just
generally working whenever you stand
back and look at your your crazy life
and go man
how did this all happen yeah like every
day
sometimes i'm just like at home smoking
just like thinking about it just like
[ __ ]
can you imagine settling down having
kids and
um yeah like you know it's definitely
something i'm
being a mom that's what i like really
want to do
actually and just like sucks you know
because i wouldn't want to um
like put a child in the same situation i
was in
no you wouldn't you know so sometimes
i'm like great idea and then i'm like
not a good idea you know but sean
you know i'm almost 30 and that's what
is like really stressing me out right
now
is that what you worry about most yeah
you know 30's like life by living this
life
yeah 30's like dude i like should have
done way more
you'll see women that have been out here
since they were your age and they're
and they're like 60 now and like still
doing the same [ __ ] i'm like
no please don't let it be me do you
think there's something inside your
like subconscious that makes you feel
like this is what you deserve
um no i don't think i deserve this i
think i'm just being lazy
that's all it is i deserve that you do
deserve a better life yeah i definitely
do i mean i was sober with my wife for
like two years you know
um it was cool
yeah i just like exercised and like
watch tv
yeah stuff's pretty cool you know it's a
lot better than
like stressing out about making money
for crack and like
trying to make money so you can [ __ ]
make other people happy
yeah is that the only time you've been
in love um
no not really i mean kind of
like she i feel like just because she
like left me
before i got saved by and stuff and we
were fighting
you know um i feel like that
is why it's like sticking a lot you know
and of course i loved her and she was
like the love of my life but
i don't know i keep trying to replace
her with other people
right now you know my god girl [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] your squirrel [ __ ] you know if you
got a good personality please come and
distract me
like yeah i mean i try to find these
little traits that remind me of her
you know it's hard what do you think
living this life and
interacting with the people that you do
work with uh
has taught you about human nature
like you respect men less do you
you know i just like feel bad for people
i mean sometimes i'm just like damn i
would hate to be like
that you're seeing people at their most
devious
yeah basically that's exactly the word i
was thinking of too
it's like sexual deviancy is just like
crazy
i'm just like whoa so now that you've
been exposed to it
over and over and over again do you
think you could ever
live a square life oh yeah definitely i
can't wait to get the [ __ ] over this
year
yeah oh yeah that's funny oh yeah good
answer
what's the most important lesson you've
learned um
god dude i don't even know i couldn't
even tell you really it's like so many
like um you know you can't [ __ ]
go to sleep around people you know
that's pretty good god i just like got
housing
you know like this corona [ __ ] is like
you were on the street before yeah i was
um i wasn't like really on the street
because like you know i make really good
money
um so i was living in like hotels like
you know but just go night by night yeah
you know that [ __ ]
sucks you know so um but you know i have
really bad asthma and i spent a lot of
time in like icu
and stuff so um
yeah so luckily like the corona thing
kind of like worked in my favor
you know so i ended up getting housing
um
i was supposed to move into my place
like this week
you know so i'm really excited you know
it's kind of something i like to look
forward to
so my list of things to do before i'm 30
like get housing
it's like a huge sign of stability and
stuff you know
yeah what's the craziest thing you've
seen in your years on the street
ah so many i've seen like there's so
many crazy people i've seen people get
shot stabbed raped [ __ ] robbed
everything dude i've seen so much i've
seen people [ __ ] in the street like
it's just crazy
i [ __ ] i'm just like well nothing
even phases me anymore
to be honest yeah
but you know the craziest thing that i
have done is like okay i never thought
i'd say this like on camera too
but i recently like had a client that
was like
i don't know i was just like will you
pee on my face and i was like dude yes
made me feel so much better i had to
hold my girlfriend's hand and stuff
though
so i was like come on you're gonna share
this moment with me yes
but yeah made me feel a lot better did
something made you feel better too yeah
i mean [ __ ] he liked it so it was a
really disrespect
yeah yeah whatever it is
do you have kids no i have no kids but
i'm like i like
want kids really bad to be honest you
know it's just like i get
i just keep choosing around people and
you know and it's hard to have babies
with a girl
you know so what do you think
makes you keep choosing the wrong people
um
you know what i think it's just because
like
anybody to distract me you know
because if i'm like by myself that's
when i like freak out
you know it's hard for me to be by
myself like i literally cannot walk
outside without people being like
me i was like people following me like
it's crazy
you know so it's like it's just
whoever's there really and
everybody's always there everyone on the
streets knows you
yeah it's like crazies i don't even know
like anybody
you know these people just know me you
know they like watch me all the time
it's crazy so if you could live a new
life what do you wish
would have been different um you know i
should have just like
not done dope that day you know a lot of
stuff
actually you know maybe i should have
sold it i don't even know
couldn't tell him everything kind of
seemed like a wrong turn do you regret
not living a
a square life kind of
you know but i feel like that was kind
of like a decision that like
whoever god or somebody made you know
like
when i was a kid are you religious um
yeah
yeah um i wasn't like for a while
because my mom she was like
crazy christian lady you know um
yeah so i was like totally like ah
anarchy
you know but um now that i'm older i'm
like of course like i understand better
you know
so i definitely believe in like my god
i guess it's a way to think about it
yeah all righty thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah
very nice talking with you god it's so
hot in here
i don't start crying god i hate that